plane has crashed in india in the state
of kerala
it's an air india plane uh which was
traveling
from dubai let's bring in sky reporter
neville lazarus who
joins us on the phone from delhi we have
some pictures
it is night time there as you can see
obviously um
a little bit difficult to see what's
going on there neville what can you tell
us about
about what's possibly happened i was
saying
yes uh this plane was coming from dubai
to uh
to land in in the corridor airport it
uh it's been raining very heavily in
kerala we are in the middle of a monsoon
season it
it landed and it's kidded uh because
this airport
the the the runway is also a tabletop
or a tabletop runway it skidded and then
it broke into a number of pieces there
are
you could see on uh some images of off
the plane in
in pieces there were about 191
passengers and crew on that flight
including some 10 infants at the moment
evacuation
and emergency services are happening at
the site
about 30 to 40 people we have been told
have been taken
are injured have been taken to the
hospital uh
according to one of the one of the
members of parliament he's
he's he's spoken on the phone to an
indian channel saying that one of the
pilots has died
but at the moment we cannot confirm it
there are no casualty reports
for the moment as rescue operations are
still happening
must remind you that we are in the
middle of a very heavy
monsoon season kerala is experiencing a
very heavy
rain over the last uh 24 hours in fact
in in in parts of udaki 15 people
had died today because of landslides and
uh and and and the situation in terms of
the monsoons is still very much
prevalent in this in this region uh we
will
we will keep an eye on this and bring
you more information as and when we get